golpeando ollas y sartenes con un claro
mensaje devuélveme mi vacuna miles de
manifestantes se reunieron frente al
palacio presidencial de argentina
pidiendo la renuncia de más funcionarios
del gobierno por el escándalo de las
inyecciones vip y contra el coronavirus
una vergüenza lo que hicieron una
vergüenza que hay prioridades para los
abuelos los maestros enfermeros los
policías trabajadores un colectivero
colectivo la gente que trabaja para
ellos
y él
las protestas llegan después de que a
principios de mes se revelara que unos
70 políticos y personas cercanas a ellos
pudieron saltarse la fila de espera de
las vacunas contra el cob y 19 lo que
obligó a dimitir al entonces ministro de
sanidad
ginés gonzález garcía el presidente
alberto fernández dijo que el incidente
era reprobable pero que las vacunas
serán un tema delicado que no debía
politizarse pero terminemos con la
payasada yo le pido a los fiscales y al
jueces que hagan lo que deben
el delito no hay ningún tipo penal en
argentina que diga será castigado el que
vacuna a otro que se adelantó en las
filas no es el único país sudamericano
que se enfrenta a un escándalo de
corrupción en el acceso a las vacunas en
pero unos 500 funcionarios del gobierno
han sido acusados entre ellos el ex
presidente martín vizcarra señalado de
vacunarse antes de tiempo